jan ihre wut ist tatsächlich etwas was
ich bei alexander mining überhaupt nicht
spüren konnte obwohl man das ja meinen
könnte dass jemand nach seinem anschlag
auf sein leben nach solchen brutalen
wochen im koma
tatsächlich so etwas wie wut verspürt
ich habe bei ihm entschlossenheit
gemerkt aber tatsächlich eine große
freundlichkeit und einen großartigen
sinn für humor aber erspart tatsächlich
nicht mit sehr eindeutigen worten für
putin putins regime und für all die
menschen die bleiben putin rund um die
welt unterstützen und dazu gehört nun
einmal vollkommen unstrittig
er hat schröder und für die hat er eben
bemerkenswert deutliche worte gefunden
hat gesagt dass ich würde ein laufschuh
putins sei der mörder beschützt und ich
persönlich glaube dass das auch noch mal
eine enorme auswirkung haben wird aus ja
auf die gesellschaftliche rolle auf das
gesellschaftliche bild auf gerhard
schröder denn alexei navalny der sich
schon sein leben lang damit seit
jahrzehnten damit beschäftigt korruption
in russland aufzudecken geldströme in
russland aufzudecken hat eben auch bei
uns ins gespräch gebracht dass er fest
davon ausgehen dass gerd schröder nicht
nur die offizielle zahlung von
russischen unternehmen bekommt sondern
eben auch noch verdeckte zahlungen für
den job den er für gut ihn erledigt
und das ist ein vorwurf der den
deutschen behörden und aber auch der
deutschen politik durchaus zu denken
geben sollte denn wie gesagt niemand
kennt sich damit besser aus als alexei
navalny und alexei navalny war bereit
sein leben zu geben um eben genau solche
geldströme zu recherchieren wie hatte
ein alexej nawalny ansonsten auf dich
gewöhnt es waren sehr schwere wochen für
ihn auch körperlich natürlich mit dem
giftanschlag dann das koma der lange
aufenthalt im krankenhaus ist er jetzt
wieder komplett fit
also ich habe gesehen als er sich in
wasser eingeschenkt hat dass seine hand
so ein bisschen gezittert hat und er hat
gesagt das ist noch ein bisschen schwer
ist mit der links rechts koordination
bei seien bei seinen händen vor allem
nach diesem
anschlag mit einem nerven kampfstoff auf
den diese koordinations schwächen
vermutlich zurückgeben aber insgesamt
muss man schon sagen das war eine freude
und es war beeindruckend zu sehen wie
gut gelaunt neugierig kampfeslustig
alexei navalny war ich habe nicht nur
gestern getroffen
zusammen mit den kollegen philipp ihr
tor von alexander wirth sprach sondern
ich habe ihn auch zufällig vor einigen
tagen getroffen hat sich in einem park
spazieren war sah ich auf einmal ein
schlaksiger mann der mir bekannt vorkam
schaute etwas genauer hin und sagt dass
es tatsächlich alexei navalny ja dort
mit seiner frau und seinem sohn
spazieren war und ein bisschen haben wir
auch darüber gestern gerät das waren so
führen dass herzerwärmendes bild zu
sehen dass dieser mann den putin tot
sehen wollte der dem tod so nah gekommen
ist wie man den tod marginal kommen kann
dass dieser mann darüber diese wiese
spazierte mit seinem sohn mit seiner
frau und und das getan hat was er bei
uns im interview auch beschrieben hat
das leben genossen er hat gesagt er
fühlt sich so unglaublich lebendig
gefühlt bei diesem spaziergang bei dem
regen der auf seine haut gebracht ist
bei dem wind den er gespürt hat also ich
habe in keiner weise einen alexei
navalny erlebt der irgendwie
angeschlagen wirklich wirkte sondern
lebensfroh und voller lust aufs leben
kann man fast sagen und auch voller lust
auf die politische auseinandersetzung
mit wladimir putin nach dem was er da
durchgemacht hat recht gesagt ist es
fast etwas überraschend wenn man jetzt
hört dass er im park spazieren war hier
in berlin einfach so weil die
bedrohungslage ist natürlich noch lange
nicht vorbei wie vorsichtig ist denn
dabei nie jetzt nachdem er weiß mit
wasser im gift er attackiert worden ist
alexei navalny ist natürlich sehr
vorsichtig alexander meyer wird
natürlich auch beschützt aber letztes
jahr weil wie gesagt auch er hat es mit
gegnern zu tun deren verhalten und
benehmen und skrupellosigkeit er nicht
ändern kann und etwas zeit lieben ich
danach ausrichten die letzte frage wie
wir ihn gestellt haben war
gehen sie davon aus dass sie lange genug
leben um ein putin russland ohne
wladimir putin zu
leben und er hat lange lange gezögert
und nachgedacht und sagt am ende sagt er
weiß es nicht er möchte nur alles dafür
tun dass seine kinder ein russland ohne
die herrscher von wladimir putin erleben
also haben wir jemanden getroffen der in
sich ruht der diesen diesen kampf gegen
die korruption und gegen das regime
russland über alles stellt der uns auch
ganz klar gesagt dass zum beispiel seine
frau ihm das nicht verzeihen würde wenn
er diesen kampf aufgeben und er sich
trotzdem einen bemerkenswerten sinn für
humor bewahrt hat der auch mit dieser
new york vergiftung in gewisser weise
immer noch humorvoll umgehen er sagte
uns er kämpft seit jahren und jahren und
jahren dagegen dass in russland aufgrund
von korruption nichts funktioniert die
sozialsysteme nicht die verkehrssysteme
nicht die bahn nicht nichts funktioniert
so richtig in russland und dann sagt er
lächelnd wie man an mir sieht
funktioniert nicht mal wieder so richtig
passt auf jeden fall eine sehr starke
aussage sein plan war es ja zurück nach
russland zurückkehren ist das noch immer
der fall wo es gerade bei mir gesagt den
kampf will er weiter führen aber weder
ihn auch wirklich aus russland führen
absolut nicht er ist fest entschlossen
diesen kampf wieder zurück nach russland
zu tragen
es scheint ja das erklärte ziel von
putin gewesen zu sein
alexei navalny für immer zum schweigen
zu bringen da haben wir gestern erlebt
dass es eindeutig nicht gelungen und
alexei navalny hat uns gesagt ich habe
kein anderes land
ich bin nicht deutscher wie hier ich
habe nur russland russland ist meine
heimat oder oster gehe ich zurück und
alexander meine kollegin alexandra
würzbach hat ihn dann gefragt was werden
sie denn dann als erstes machen wenn sie
nach moskau zurückkehren und er sagte ja
musik vermutlich erst mal eine wohnung
suchen weil die russischen behörden sein
ganzes vermögen alles was er hat und das
ist jetzt kein gewaltiges vermögen
dagegen werde über ein bankkonto und ein
ort an dem man lebt im prinzip
beschlagnahmen konfisziert hat und er
gar nicht weiß ob er da wieder hin kann
er sagte unsere weiß nicht ob er
vielleicht bei der einreise sofort
beachtet wird aber sagt er weiß nicht
was sie da erwartet
aber er ist fest entschlossen nach
russland zurück zu kehren
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei b
schau dich hier das nächste video an und
vergiss nicht zu abonnieren